welcome back to new rockstars the first
two episodes of marvel's hawkeye on
disney plus present to us a knives out
esque murder mystery that we have
enlisted the help of an insider from the
hawkeye series to help solve this is
rogue theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles we
love i'm eric voss going rogue with me
today is good friend of the show and
daughter of the year jessica clemons
uh also of course the head of new
rockstar's own bro mafia is empty what's
going on bro don't touch my car bro what
the heck going on bro
i don't i'm trying to act like them i
can't do it
you're doing great man i want you to
stick with that the whole episode and we
are so excited to welcome two new rock
stars the wickedly talented performer
from hawkeye episode one who played
ant-man in rogerson musical please
welcome to the show nico de jesus
welcome nikki thanks for having me does
this mean that i'm also the sexiest man
alive
oh my god
that's yes
get this man a
yeah so we're going to get into the
whole mystery at the heart of hawkeye
who killed armand decaying the third you
have some ideas of who you think it is
i'm sure but i think there's going to be
some bigger twists to this but first we
have nico here so we gotta ask you about
rogers the musical if that's okay please
ask okay so i i want you to talk about
the whole process of bringing i could do
this all day to the stage like the
lyrics the choreography the book the
score the set design the casting how
collaborative was this process with the
marvel studios team what was your level
of input as the sexiest man alive auntie
well you know my agents actually sent me
a weird email saying hey they're
they're they wanna they wanna hire
dances for a marvel show and so just
send in the tape it was one of those
things so i just sent him a tape of me
dancing and then his tape of me singing
and then a week later my agent said hey
so marvel wants you for this job they
want to fly you they want you to go to
atlanta and they want you to do this job
show up the first day of rehearsal not
exactly sure what the heck is going on
and so they go through and the
choreographer josh fergus he looks at
like all the six foot guys he's like you
guys need to be the tatari and this is
gonna be loki this is gonna be the
battle of new york for all the other new
yorkers and i'm like oh cool what am i
doing here why am i here right now and
he's like and this is my my friend he's
like
this is gonna be the hulk this thing be
captain america and he points to me he's
like and you're gonna be ant-man and i
was like
hmm ant-man was not in the battle of new
york
but uh sure
this will be great this will be really
fun so yeah so just it was we were there
we were there in atlanta for three weeks
rehearsing and then we filmed at the
beautiful fox theater in atlanta um and
it was crazy it was it was actually one
of our like my first job being back
since the pandemic didn't know that
jeremy renner was gonna be there on on
one of our shoot dates and this dude
just handsome man walks in with the suit
on and i was like that's uh
that's jeremy renner that is hawkeye
it's like that's an avenger he's here
and so and he's literally watching you
right now pretend to be ant-man so this
is great
wow so did you know that this was going
to be for the hawkeye series or did you
just think some marvel property you know
how marvel is we had no clue no idea
there was i even i even forget i didn't
forget the code name for it we showed up
we had i had no idea what it was i
forget what the code name for it was and
we showed up at rehearsal space like hi
we're here for this whatever the code
name was and then
finally in rehearsal they revealed what
we were going to be doing
oh yeah i love that they can
compartmentalize it that way we talked
to it enriquez who is the commercial guy
on wandavision he's a friend of ours
from improv in l.a and he's like yeah i
just came in to do commercials like
marvel related commercials i had no idea
this would be your own division
so that's so funny and then we had no
idea and they had like
the my friend that played captain
america and my friend that played thor
it was an actual captain america shield
i may or may not have like stolen photos
holding both of them maybe we don't know
but
yeah hawkeye's bow was that like it was
uh it was quite the experience i was
geeking out the entire time
we could tell you you looked like you
were having a lot of fun playing ant-man
because like it was even hawk i asked
like ant-man wasn't there and it goes to
you like doing the shake the sway
oh yeah it was hilarious the
choreographer i thought he was gonna
have me do something cool there because
you know every avenger they had their
own little like i think was ant-man
flies and you don't hear a sound i
thought i was gonna like do a flip or
something and he's like oh no i actually
want you to do what the girls are doing
because i think that'd be really funny
and i was like sure why not
sure it would be pretty funny you're
right let's do it it's sold perfectly
like the editing and you're just
delivery of that it was kind of like
yeah i know i wasn't supposed to be here
but i'm here
anyway oh yeah the entire time though i
was a little scared i was like oh
they're gonna realize that
ant-man wasn't actually in this and i
was gonna get fired but no but then when
i heard that when i heard that the
jeremy renner line about ant-man i was
like oh i have a close-up coming up here
we go
good on you for making the most of it
and we gotta ask could there be other
like songs from rogers the musical that
we might hear on an original cast
recording other marvel easter eggs i
mean
i don't know about that i do know that
they were very excited about this i do
know that they have been talking about
trying to cross over into the musical
world and this was like something and
this was a and this was a big deal for
them this was a huge deal this was a
heat show for them to cross over and do
this they got actually mark shaman who
is producer or composer
he wrote the music
of course got adam pascal mr one song
glory from rent to do the music and yeah
i know oh and yeah i tried to i was
gonna try and get him to come in my to
come in here and say hi to us because
he's on tour with me right now but he's
he's busy he's busy right now but yeah
[Applause]
i know i really wanted to get him to
come in here real quick but you know
adam pass falls down i love you adam
fastballs
call things but i will say that that
there is somewhere like a four minute
long version of this number i don't know
where it is but i know it's release the
rogers
spotify.com i know it's somewhere so
there is there is a longer version of
this entire of this entire so funny
that's so amazing so exciting to hear
uh well nico again thank you for joining
us we want you now to cross over into
our world to figure out this hawkeye
mystery because you know you you had
this role on the show you don't know
everything absolutely watching it now as
a fan yeah yes great well let's dive
into it hawkeye episode one jack's
elderly uncle armand duquesne iii chats
up kate during the party and kate
recalls attending brunches that is
brownstone when she was a kid suggesting
that the dukanes and the bishops could
go way back but now armond distrust jack
and eleanor's engagement kate overhears
armand and eleanor arguing armand's like
i gave you this opportunity he threatens
her i have powerful friends too and then
we learn that eleanor owns a private
security company never a good sign and
uh we're not quite sure whether or not
she killed her husband derek by the way
that's all in the breakdown but at this
auction armand tells jack that he's
reached his breaking point with eleanor
things are about to get ugly they get in
a bidding war for hawkeye's ronin sword
and then during the robbery jack steals
the sword and kate finds armand's corpse
in his home slain by a sword injury
along with a bowl of armand the third
bran butterscotches the same
butterscotches that jack offers kate
after a vicious fencing match where he
tried to downplay his skills but then
eventually revealed then when he parries
like you know muscle memory and then
kate obviously suspects jack now i think
we're all meant to suspect shaq tony
dalton he's great at playing a villain
but there's obviously a deeper
conspiracy behind armand's murder so
what do you guys think that conspiracy
is i'm gonna go first since the new the
noob is gonna go first so that you guys
can go for it so you guys can chime in
and help me out here because i'm not the
professional here
just just so you know too like i uh i'm
not as well versed in this this is like
48 hours of research but here we go
is it jack or is it jacques ducane
um
he might be the you know
the swordsman um
i think that there is something to do
with the butler that we saw very quickly
in the um
in the auction scene i think that maybe
him
and jacques may be teamed up
and maybe they had something to do with
the killing of uncle armand and then
also and also jacques also said
inheriting money from maybe you know
he's all he's inheriting money from the
bishops but also maybe he's inheriting
money from his uncle i think you're
absolutely on to something i think
obviously jack or jacques has to be
involved somehow right the evidence is
there i think you're right to to pull on
the string of the money follow the money
right like there's something going back
with the bishops with their financial
troubles in that prologue scene and with
the duquesne how he gave eleanor this
opportunity the fact that she now runs a
private security firm financial troubles
gone
like
some solution fell from above
and i'm just dying to know what that
financial incentive was
i
ultimately agree with nico
i agree with nico
i like the idea of jack being in debt um
especially because during the auction
scene he was like it's okay i'm not
gonna need money for that much longer
like he was like and his dad was like
i'm buying this so you don't buy it like
you don't have the money to do so he
didn't want the mom you know kate
bishop's mom and him getting together i
think they were working together and now
that they're together i think uh like
ultimately jack's idea is like i'm gonna
get into wealth this way and i'm gonna
kill her but i'm gonna kill my dad or my
uncle who's getting in the way of this
fortune that could possibly happen i
like the idea though that kate bishop's
mom is also bad though and the mom is
ultimately the one that killed the uncle
um they could be working together
because i think the people that broke
into the auction still have to be like
the security working for her and she
hired them i refuse to believe that this
woman's all good like it's she's up to
something with him and i want that scene
of the break and i was like that's her
people i immediately was like that's a
people she needs that watch he needs
that watch someone like this is not
it's too easy it's too easy to be like
oh the the nephew did it to the uncle so
i'm like no
give it to me right i do not trust
eleanor bishop at oh i didn't have to
chick for one second like i just i think
she killed
the daddy um haley's dad and i think
that she killed armand as well haley's
dad
catchy the actress haley steinbeck
father oh my gosh
stop mg's protecting breaking news
i think she killed kate's dad and i
think that she's behind the um our mom's
murder as well it just seems that you
know because they had that argument
right before his death and it's just
like i just think that she's a really
bad person and
um if you see if you go back to episode
one when she's talking to kate and we
see her do that weird like um thing with
the with her fork and the food into her
mouth yeah she has like some really
unique reflexes i think that she has
more skills she okay real quick
boy so it i literally agree so and also
in the beginning with the the animation
and like the title sequence her mom is
always standing within an inch of her
daughter winning
everything
do it do it and that line i love the
line so much but that line of like
when um haley steinfeld did all the bad
stuff with the bell and she was like
you think you're invincible because
you're young and rich but i haven't
always been young and rich so i'm like
she got to where she was doing something
better like i was like she's lived a
life she has she has tall tales i'm like
she did something bad you're right and
the fact that like kate bishop used the
telltale sign to her the smoking gun was
the fact that jack duquesne was lying
about his abilities and they just pulled
that random perry out of nowhere clearly
uh eleanor bishop is doing the same
thing both with the carrot trick and
then in the opening shot like there's a
shot of like kate bishop's bedroom and
framed pictures of everything you see a
woman doing a handstand on a cliff
that's obviously not kate she's a 10
year old girl that's got to be eleanor
who's doing crazy gymnastics in rio
de janeiro wherever that is like that
this woman's got some skills and i think
we're going to see it you know rio de
janeiro wherever it is
well there is a cliff somewhere in south
america
yes
you got it you got it
they're both aware of it i think they
were both aware they both didn't really
seem to care that armand was dead
they're like police will handle it
probably because we own the police right
i just want to know how high up this
goes i know how low it goes i think the
tracksuit bros are working for them as
well
but i i wonder if they have bought off
some of the city government and that's
why you know i'm i'm shipping hard like
i'm pushing hard i'm on the train i
worship at the altar i bend the knee to
kingpin like
oh my god i wanna see dinaprio in this
please lord please it might that'd be
really cool if i knew i would spoil that
obviously if i knew you were just like
yeah
but i have no idea i would have told you
all already niko tell us the truth we
know you know come on please all right
well i think it's clear enough that like
eleanor married into the bishop family
money i think he had money derek bishop
did as a kid uh and i think his family
goes way back with the duquesnes but i
think he was kind of a screw-up he just
kind of had that classic screw-up energy
like what i like to go down to atlantic
city sometimes
the house is gonna break my way this
weekend wait until you see dolph and
then she's like oh god can just a battle
of new york happened
please oh thank god i also think it's
crazy that like did eleanor bishop know
this battle was coming the fact that
she's like you know sometimes the
solution is going to come from above
your dad's going to go downstairs i will
also go downstairs
like did she just happen to see that
wormhole open up while they're arguing
definitely i don't know if she knew but
she definitely had to kill the dad
because when haley was looking for when
kate i need to call her haley
the great casting though it did look
like a little version of haley styles
it did young kate was looking so long
screaming mom dad i was like okay
they're dead and then when the mom
showed up i was like
mommy oh mother mother
mommy mom our 3.5 million dollar
penthouses is going to say
mommy where's the
yeah
i'm also i'm very surprised has this
happened before i don't think it has but
this is a great opportunity for like the
storytelling arc of having a villainous
mother of like yeah she pushed him off
the freaking half like blown up roof of
your guys's penthouse suite like and no
one's gonna think of it because they're
gonna be like oh yeah an aliens were
attacking so we can't really pin it on
your mom pushing them off a cliff so
it has to be yeah like i think that she
was literally like waiting for like it
was a perfect opportunity it's like i
could kill this guy i'm just gonna throw
my body into the rubble and be like oh
my god it was aliens it was aliens and
not me yeah wow it was it was too
perfect too perfect oh my gosh
oh my gosh that's the crazy thing i'm
gonna kill you honey come out here look
at these aliens
the only thing i could really think of
like how she could have known is like
maybe she was working with hydra because
like hydra was injured boy
boy
don't talk about it it would be crazy
it would be nuts if she was connected
i don't know who knows and like maybe
her powerful friends are val who knows
oh my gosh okay now our mind is racing
oh my god my next theory has a lot to do
with this so don't talk about sorry okay
see this is always like the crazy option
but should we just discuss skrull like
could the fact that squirrels they were
in orbit they would have known alien
invasion is a foot and could have
alerted her like
is possible could she be
baranki the evil score the first evil
scroll we meet in the mcu i'm just
saying oh my god
that's a really good point because the
squirrels are in orbit that's really
really smart i'm just gonna give myself
yeah just shove it in there
uh empty i'm gonna give you the point
there for for bringing hydra into this
hydra always seems to
have their finger on the pulse they know
what's coming on
i appreciate it man i got like glitter
on my chest now it's like i came back
from a rave well we're going to talk
more about this watch that came up in
the auction i think that could be the
key to a lot of this and i want to hear
your thoughts on it but uh first there
is a brand new latest obsession shirt
inspired by hawkeye available at
newrockstarsmerch.com you gotta get your
hands on this it is awesome these are
limited edition shirts once they sell
out they're gonna be retired to the blue
dungeon with me where i i stitch them
together into a quilt and i wrap myself
in it and i just like sweat out you know
that's what he uses to try to escape
i'm in a tower i can't tell you where
but it's just there's no door to this
room i don't know how he got here but
it's all blue uh anyway and if you get
those shirts when you get the latest
obsession you'll get the added option of
writing in a custom shout out that'll
appear at the bottom of our inside
marvel after show so that's a cool
little perk so uh get these uh shirts
and all of our merch options on your
extras merch.com uh but we want to thank
some people who sponsored this episode
starting with our friends at bluetooth
guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can help give
you that confidence where it counts
bluetooth is the unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
jupiter form and at a fraction of the
cost you can take them anytime day or
night so you can plan ahead or be ready
for whenever an opportunity arises
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package so if
you can benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our audience drive
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code rogue check out just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month for free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring the show we also want to
thank stance socks around the office
we've been rocking socks from one of the
sponsors of this episode stance and they
are both incredibly comfortable but also
very well designed they feel great and
they're just a fun way to suddenly show
off our fandoms founded in 2009 stance
apparel has reinvented socks t-shirts
and more they have a sharp focus on
comfort quality and creativity stance
brings an atypical aesthetic alongside
some of pop culture's hottest
collaborators for the ultimate in style
and self-expression because everything
you wear should be a direct extension of
who you are and how you feel they are a
great match with the new rockstars
audience because of their collaborations
with brands you love like batman pixar
star wars and marvel some days you just
feel like having thanos on your ankle
and stance helps you do that in style
the stance philosophy is that a perfect
fit is more important than simply
fitting in those who feel good do good
so go see for yourself just head on over
to stance.com and pick out whatever
styles you like enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance and we want to thank upstart for
sponsoring us if you dread looking at
your credit card statements you're not
alone the weight of debt can feel
crippling but upstart can help you on
your path to financial freedom upstart
is a fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you can
check your rate without impacting your
credit score in minutes for loans
between one thousand and fifty thousand
dollars you can even receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan so find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com rogue that's
upstart.com rogue don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you load amounts we determined based on
your credit income certain other
information provided in your loan
application again that's upstart.com
rogue all right back to these first two
episodes of hawkeye one interesting
detail from hawkeye episode one was this
watch that was in this off the books
auction in the wine cellar that they
recovered from the wreckage of avengers
compound along with all these other
things they were auctioning off and then
of course this was robbed which we have
suggested might have been a planned
robbery from someone from the inside
maybe eleanor bishop the tracksuit
mafia's primary objective was that watch
they said everything else is secondary
infinity stone secondary start goblin
secondary a bimtek secondary but this
much this watch
[Laughter]
so who had this wash up their ass
in vietnam for so long uh no i want to
know like uh they did successfully
obtain it there was a guy looked at it
then lucky the pizza dog attacked him
but it seems like he was able to recover
that watch that seems to be the whole
objective to this you know and then
they're worried that oh now we got this
like kate bishop character who's like
aware of what we're doing so they're
trying to like cover up this watch like
whose watch was this why was it so
important to steal what do you guys
think i i'll go first because i have no
insight i don't know i'm joking i think
it's the strucker watch from watching
i think it's a strucker watch i think
it's very important there's ties to it
that something in it that they need to
get and that's why wando is keeping
imagining all these commercials that
struck her sorry struck her stuff
you're gonna bleep that out so i think
it's a very important watch because
there's something inside of it and the
only person that has any kind of
knowledge of this thing existing right
now other than these people was wanda
and that's where we were getting that
first taste from wanda's visions in the
commercials
that's pretty cool
like the fact that she's manifested this
now this is real these products are real
you can get hydra soak you can get uh
whatever you want i would love if they
like they just break into like a like a
supermarket like get the soap bro if
they get all the soap
get the soap it's very important you
gotta carve it
i think that the watch could be tony
stark related because like you know
we've seen it far from home that we have
the glasses and like if this was
avengers mansion so like tony stark
stuff is all over the place that
everyone wants tony stark's technology
like we saw in iron man 2 at the
beginning as soon as iron man came out
he's like all right i'm iron man
everyone just wanted this technology so
there's probably something in that watch
some nanotech something or some tony
secrets that they wanna just yeah i mean
in civil war he had a wristwatch right
that he would
turn like that that's where it all came
up all over himself uh but also the uh
phrasing
you know you talk about bluetooth your
mind
uh but i'm thinking like also he had the
the wristwatch tech for the pim tech
that he used as quantum navigators like
maybe he could have encoded that in a
wristwatch that he just left he's like i
want to keep one of these i like that
because like we do have quantum mania
coming up and i suspect that the word
quantum mania is probably in reference
to you know the whole quantum energy um
thing that's going to happen um like
everyone's gonna want quantum energy to
go like harness it like time travel all
that stuff yeah so like it would make
sense if that was part of it and it's
like all right let's get that watch
technology so we can just find a way to
go through the quantum realm and do
sketchy yeah
i i like that that watch is so important
and they got a bunch of people in track
seats to go get it like
absolutely i thought that was hilarious
they're like we gotta it would like ski
just a ski mask justice yeah who who say
bro like in case you had any confusion
over which gang this was to watch
and put it on their vans and then also
like because cassie just like
looked at his yeah he shows him
what are you doing you can see through
it
a little bit more like emotional here
and as soon as i saw the russians i was
like oh natasha i was like oh i was like
oh maybe um maybe this watch has
sentimental value
and maybe elena maybe sent them to go
get the watch
oh and maybe this is something of like i
don't know maybe this is very broke but
i was like maybe i don't know maybe it
belongs to natasha this is
another thing that connects her to her
sister and this is something that's very
sentimental to her and as as soon as the
russians attracts he's popped up i was
just like oh elena also i just love you
elaine so i just want her to pop up
anyways but i was like this is another
way besides her wanting to kill clint
this is another way to get her into the
series and kind of mixed in with
everything that is a
fascinating taste
like this yeah there is like ivan the
leader of the gang we've always wondered
who's the ivan who's natasha's dad in
this universe you know like father of
ivan is he dead is he actually dead is
he still alive somewhere but even though
echo seems to be their manager a manager
is not a ceo a manager is not a client
you know managers are someone who
oversees does the day shift or the night
shift you know so i think there's gonna
be a lot of tears to this criminal
organization a lot of a lot of whips out
to other uh pieces of the operation yeah
i think elena could have been involved
in that for sure in fact and we know
elena's coming into this show we know
she's she and valor targeting hawkeye so
nico i'm giving you a point for that i
think that's fascinating uh and jessica
i gotta give you a point as well for the
strucker watch i did not think of that i
love that one such a good idea i love
that yeah that's so cool all right so we
are all even up here it is anyone's game
but before we get to rogue questions one
more thank you to our sponsor mack
weldon you're busy so stop thinking
about what to wear and just embrace the
radically efficient mac welding daily
wear system the daily wear system is a
selection of clothes rooted in smart
design made with performance fabrics
built to work together from breathable
t-shirts and polos to stylish button-ups
and shorts underwear and beyond mac
weldon makes it easy for you to dress
for work leisure and play around here at
new rockstars we are big fans of their
long-sleeve t-shirts they are perfect
for fall weather or even a chilly movie
theater where you know we're starting to
spend some more time these days and you
gotta look sharp in that concession line
for the ultimate lazy sunday their ace
sweatshorts have a modern tailoring and
pair perfectly with their ultra soft
ultra upgraded pima tees for weekend
travels both near and far the silvernet
polo and radius shorts are their perfect
high-tech highly packageable combo so
buy some time this season with the
macweldon daily wear system for 20 off
your first order visit macweldon.com
rogue and enter promo code rogue that's
macweldon.com
rogue promo code rogue for 20 off mac
weldon radically efficient wardrobing
all right it is thanksgiving week
everybody gobble gobble black friday
we're eating a lot of food we're buying
a lot of things that probably won't ship
to us until january but anyway uh i
wanna know
uh an honor thanksgiving pitch uh what
side dish or dessert or other option
your favorite marvel hero or your
favorite marvel villain would bring to
the thanksgiving dinner table
[Music]
in honor of you know my boy nico uh i
think i would say ant-man brings in
if you remember from ant-man 2 there's
these really adorable um tardigrade
animals in the microverse water bears if
you just made them really big and then
this cooked one and just like here's my
thanksgiving meal a weird microverse
animal uh i think that'd be hilarious
i'm gonna say that shangchi i don't know
if any of you ever been to like an uh an
asian holiday feast we don't typically
do like proper thanksgiving food we
always do like oh here's some uh noodles
in lumpia if you're filipino i'm going
to say that shang cheese he's he's
bringing dumplings he's pretty he's
bringing some soup dumplings over
to
our thanksgiving
yeah actual actual edible food instead
of like a poorly cooked turkey you know
absolutely yeah
i'm not a big fan of like a good grocery
soup
you have to work so hard he's bringing
dumplings and boba
i mean that sounds like a dream
thanksgiving to me that's
hell yeah i'm all about that so i
think it'd be cute if it's uh peter
parker and he was just like oh yeah uh
up may made some lemon bars and there's
only like enough for six people
i feel like all the other avengers would
bring like actual dishes like doctor
strange would make like an actual buffet
come to the table and peter parker shows
up and just like his normal like jacket
and shoes just be like lemon bars here
with the foil still on like it'd be
something you feel
oh
i love that i gotta give the point i
mean of those options they all sound
great but i would want to have
thanksgiving with chongqi if that's
gonna be honest
you get the point you get the winning
point and nico that makes you the winner
of this episode of rogue theory and just
the winner of the week honestly for the
hawkeye premiere like what an amazing
cameo and performance we we hope to see
you more in the mcu
i just want to say thank you so much for
having me and i wanted to say thank you
all so much i found this channel during
the pandemic
and
your episodes they truly helped every
week every day getting a new new
rockstar notification saying there's a
new video and seeing the three of you on
there really helped keep me you know
happy throughout the pandemic so thank
you all so much and this was this was
amazing thank you so much this is so
cool that's so sweet it's so sweet it's
dope that you're even on this show man
so like yeah i i it's thank you honestly
thank you so much for coming thanks guys
i appreciate this sexiest man alive mcu
character on rogue fusion are you
kidding me
[Laughter]
yes you are and uh and it's such an
honor uh to have you as as part of this
panel today nico for everyone watching
uh follow nico's career like this guy is
performing on stages everywhere where
are you performing next where can people
see you so right now i'm on uh i'm on
the pretty woman tour which is traveling
right now right now we're on the east
coast right now i'm in st louis but also
adam pascal who was in the episode with
me is also on tour with me right now so
if you want to see amazing if you want
to see two characters from the mcu come
watch pretty woman on tour
people will and they will literally just
be like that's the people from them
i'm telling you i'm telling you right
now uh people are discovering jonathan
larson in his universe and his works
through tick tick boom yes with
spider-man as a tick tick boom like
people are gonna find their way around
to everyone you know having grown up
with rent and with adam pascal to me
whatever but like there's gonna be a
whole new wave of kids who are like wait
what is this amazing thing it's called
musical theater uh that i can go support
anyway so yes support niko dejesus and
we thank you again for joining us here
on new rockstars what an amazing show
this was and of course jessica clemons
mt thank you guys for joining us always
a delight to share uh to share some
screen time with you guys and you can
support new rock stars and all of our
awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and if you want to
talk more about this episode of rogue
theory uh we have a new rockstars
discord server that is now open to the
public we've made some channels
available to non-patrons so that you can
be a part of a broader community of new
rockstars fans on discord if you're over
18 and interested search for new
rockstars on our your discord search
option join the conversation you can
follow me at ea boss follow me rockstars
on all of our social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
youtube of course everyone have a
wonderful holiday weekend and we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
you